hello everyone and welcome to another
really awesome game from round three of
the 2021 video world cup uh it's mikhail
krasenko versus pragananda
and both of them already defeated two
very strong opponents cressengo defeated
sabinic and the kill alexinko we've
checked out his uh
victory over alexenko and pragananda
defeated bersamina and sergician
so now this is game two of their
classical match first game was won by
pragananda
and this game a lot of you have
requested because it's really crazy so
uh you know let's just enjoy it and then
we're gonna
see what happens and in case you're
wondering uh krasenkova has been playing
chess his entire life and he's 42 years
older than than prague here
uh so quite a clash of generations
uh without further ado uh first move is
knight to f3 by krasenko
going for the ereti opening uh we have
d5 uh
d4 knight to f6 and now c4 just
you know going for a standard queen's
pawn opening and now pragananda
captures on c4 he plays d captures on c4
going for the queen's gambit
accepted variation knight to c3 and now
a6 so now black of course wants to play
on the queen side with b5
and the white will grab more space in
the center with e4 we have b5
and e5 now attacking this knight with
knight to d5 and a4 now challenging the
structure
and now usually in some variations black
will advance this pawn to b4 but not
here
here black just plays e6 and now it's
white's turn and it seems like uh
this is a free pawn but it's not free
already one upon it's the queen's gambit
accepted so he captures on b5
uh you cannot capture back as rook
captures rook would happen
so instead we have bishop to b4 now with
a double attack on the knight here
and the queen to c2 just defending this
and now
knight to b6 so uh if white would
to were to capture on a6 that doesn't
really do all that much just knight
captures you simply helps black develop
so instead we have queen to e4 attacking
this rook here and now
prague just blocks with queen to d5 now
this has all been played before of
course the knight is pinned you can grab
the queen
queen to g4 now attacking the g7 pawn
and now a captures on b5 now opening
attack
towards the white rook here so here rook
captures an a8
queen captures and now queen captures on
g7 now again this has all been played
before more than once
we have bishop captures on c3 with check
b captures and now
uh queen to a1 this is the only good
move for black now attacking the bishop
here
and sacrificing the exchange so
krasenkov grabs the rook with check we
have queen captures with eight
on h8 with check king to d7 and now
there is
one game in the database for king the d2
was played where the bishop was defended
but here
krasenko just plays bishop to e2 he
allows queen captures on c1
and it is now as of move 16 that we have
a completely new game
uh so let's see how prague continues of
course he grabs the bishop it comes with
check queen captures on c1 bishop to d1
blocking
queen captures in c3 and now not king to
f1 but blocking check with the knight
king to f1 is a pretty uh well it's
pretty
bad move for white because just queen d3
check and you can start advancing your
pawn
uh and if you don't do this and also
your bishop is just hanging
so you could play some like king to e1
but then
like i said you just advanced the pawn
and if you block with the bishop it's
not much better just queen to b1
check now you can block with the bishop
as you're going to lose it so
the knight to e1 and now you just
continue playing knight to c6 and it's a
really really tough position to handle
for
for white the pass pawn will march
forward and the
well white's pieces are just terrible
the rook here doing nothing the knight
can't move the bishop
not really all that helpful so instead
after queen captures on c3 check by
prague we have knight to d2
and now comes knight to c6 uh continuing
development
we have queen captures on h7 and now
knight
captures on d4 so what do you play here
of course we're gonna grab the f pawn
with check so queen captures on f7
king to c6 and now comes queen to f4
crestenko brings the queen back to help
out with the defense
although one also might consider just
starting to advance this past h
pawn but okay queen to f4 uh and
now knight to d5 attacking the queen we
have queen to e4 now
not allowing this knight to move so here
king to c5 unpinning it's a question
whether to unpin with queen to c
king to c5 or king to b6 uh king to c5
is what prague chooses
king to b6 would have been more prudent
but now white starts advancing his pawn
with h4
and now bishop the b7 now threatening
all sorts of nasty discoveries
but just h5 here uh he says there
there's nothing this
that scares me here but now we have
knight to b4
opening up an attack here towards the
queen and also threatening some very
nasty checks here
but white doesn't care white just
castles and he hangs his queen entirely
but not really if you if you capture the
queen you you lose the game because if
bishop captures queen then we capture
back with check and also there's a nice
royal fork here king b6 we're going to
capture the queen
and now we're up a whole rook so of
course completely winning for white so
instead after castles
uh prague now grabs the knight here
queen captures on d2
and now queen captures bishop on b7
we have knight to d5 uh and now comes
h6 uh continuing to advance this past
pawn because you can't capture if you
capture
uh then well you just lose the game now
comes queen to a7 with
check and how do you block this if you
move the king you lose the knight here
so that obviously doesn't work and if
you play knight b6 there's queen
captures on c7 check
and now you lose this knight so not
possible to capture the pawn
so here prague starts advancing his own
past pawn we have c3 but now h7
threatening to bring another queen into
the game
so queen to h6 stopping this and only
now queen to a7 with
check we have king to c4 and now
one might expect in a crazy position
such as this one to see
queen a2 check king goes back queen a7
checking goes back
and here we might have a nice uh
repetition of moves but prague already
won the first game and krasenko cannot
allow
to draw this game otherwise he's our
defeated world cup so here he plays
bishop to g4 and this
uh doesn't do all that much for him but
it keeps the game going so
uh wha what's happening here prague says
all right thank you for the free tempo
i'm just going to advance my pawn to c2
already i'm threatening to bring a queen
into the game because my queen is
covering the c1 square
so now queen to a2 with check and now
king to b4
here king to b4 allows white a lot more
maneuvering
space king to d3 uh would be pretty much
an in an instant win for black but it's
really really hard to see everything
problem is after queen to a3 check we're
going to block knight to c3
and now after we play a move like rook
to e1 or something uh then black his
has this very strong b4 move so this
could be something that
um you know eluded black while
considering this variation
and now of course if you capture then
you're no longer covering the c1 square
and black just brings the queen
into the game so here we would have to
queen our own pawn
and only after the queen moves and now
we're going to play queen captures on b4
now okay the rook is enough to guard the
square
but now queen captures an e5 and now
again you're attacking the rook there's
no better move than to capture the queen
and after you capture it we just bring a
queen into the game with check
king h2 and now queen to f4 check will
win this rook here and now of course
black is completely winning
so that's uh kind of the idea king to d3
is extremely strong here cup
um prague went uh king to b4 and it's
still a better position for black but
white has uh some more uh maneuvering
square so queen to b2 would
check king to c4 and now rook to e1
and what do you play here uh well here
the only
good move for black is queen captures on
h7
and the the thing is after this it
doesn't seem like
white has a good continuation if you try
some tricky moves like
bishop to a to check hoping that maybe
knight captures and then
you can maybe capture and then capture
here uh the problem is black just moves
and after queen to a3 checking b6 and
well black keeps his past c pawn and it
will be enough for a victory
so instead after rook to e1 uh prague
did not capture he played knight
to f4 uh but this is uh well this is
just enough for
whites to win the game here h8 was
played
krasenko brought a queen into the game
now of course you have to capture this
but now comes
rook to e4 and this is the move that uh
prague must have missed because it's the
only winning move
and there's simply no way to defend the
knight this knight is attacked twice and
this knight also
attacked by the rook you can't go here
the bishop covers that there's a pawn
here so you can defend like this
uh not much for for prague to do here he
played c5 but now rook
captures on f4 we have queen captures on
e5 but now queen
captures on c2 with check the knight of
course is pinned
king d5 and now comes queen to d2 and
now okay your upper rook but black has
some very scary past pawns here so
prague of course will start pushing them
so c4 but now there are many many ways
to continue this game white is
pretty much winning in all the lines but
krasenga chooses the absolutely
uh well uh simplest one and that is
just to trade everything off you're up a
bishop there's no point in complicating
queen captures
and now not capturing right away but
first the tricky bishop captures an e6
check
now of course the king cannot capture as
the queen would fall so king c5 and now
we trade queens captures captures
and now white is up a full piece and of
course he plays g4 now he's starting to
advance his past pawn
prague plays king to e5 now bishop to f7
with king
f4 attacking the g4 pawn but here
carsenko just played f3
defending his pawn and he was in this
position that prague will resign to the
game
as there is nothing more to be done here
the problem is once you start advancing
the pawns it's all over you can't push
this pawn because this pawn falls
and if you advance this pawn uh just
bishop to b3
the only move but it's quite sufficient
prevents this pawn from advancing blocks
this pawn and that's it you will
either pick up this pawn and then we
start advancing this spawn
or you'll have to move back with the
king and then you allow our king into
the game and then it's just a very a
very simple win
so uh very nicely done by the by the
uh 40 42 year old uh older gentleman
mikhail krasenkov who who bounces back
in the match and we'll see what happens
in the tie breaks will pragananda be
able to uh to
to win again or will uh krasenko uh
simply have uh
well a brilliant brilliant tournament
but like i said uh he was
once uh a member of the elite he was
once a top 10 player
uh in in classical chess uh and really
playing outstanding chess and you know
really really crazy chess
now uh it's such a
it's such an age i think he's like he's
exactly as old
as gary kasparov but still as you can
see very very
active and precise uh but yeah that's
the game hope you guys enjoyed it as so
many of you have requested it it was a
very nice attacking game uh so always uh
am thankful
when you guys suggest such games uh i
would like to thank
kinglongyou an anonymous person kd
nuggets hey kobernetsky and happy
birthday to jj from pp
uh for a contribution to my channel
thank you a lot i really appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the video
world cup checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the chess world
thank y'all i will see you soon and have
an excellent rest of your day